so you've obviously spent a lot of time
thinking about subscription podcast and
you recently wrote a piece about how Joe
Rogan basically could be making more
money through subscription rather than
ads or or the deal he did you had
originally made the analysis on Howard
Stern and the serious deal so maybe give
us just kind of a 1-minute summary of
the math that you're using there in the
logic behind why Rogan or somebody else
going subscription versus ads makes more
sense yeah so I think um you know I've
described it as podcasters are a bunch
of farmers and they own fertile land
right they they their only way of making
money off the land is to grow vegetables
which is a lot of work it's
back-breaking labor right and that's
advertising so they do the advertising
it's a pain in the ass to sell they have
to have some douchey salesperson who
does all the ad sales they're
negotiating and a lot of podcasters
there are often public intellectuals or
non businesspeople so to them often
they're kind of allergic to that idea
and they don't want to deal with that
and so when someone like Spotify comes
along and says look you're making twenty
million dollars a year we'll give you
twenty five thirty and come over and
we'll deal with all your ad sales I
think that's very very attractive to
them what I've been making the case for
is that there's actually a lot of oil
beneath the farmland and that's the real
value and the oil is recurring
membership subscription so when Howard
Stern went to Sirius you have this huge
public radio or not public radio but
private you know FM radio listenership
of you know I think it was like five ten
fifteen million people every day tuned
in to listen to Howard and when he went
to Sirius they fully gated him so they
said past 19 bucks a month and he can
listen to Howard Stern otherwise you can
write and in doing so that drove massive
revenue we kind of did some napkin in
math we estimate probably between 300
and 400 million dollars a year of
serious revenue as just people who want
to listen to Howard Stern right when he
did that deal he could not have gone out
and started his own radio station and
bought satellites and done all this
stuff
and cut out the middleman there had to
be a middleman either it was an FM radio
and a network or it was satellite radio
they made him the best deal my argument
with Howard Stern is that Stern should
just cut out the middleman that all the
technology that has been developed over
the last decade in podcasting makes all
of their satellites and distribution
completely irrelevant my argument is
that Stern should leave Sirius he should
start a podcast and he should basically
have the podcast cut off after 30
minutes similar to what Sam Harris does
or 10 minutes or maybe it's only for
subscribers and he should rebuild his
audience there via subscription and
charge the same amount Sirius was
charging except he gets a hundred
percent of it and if you look at his
business he needs a microphone he needs
an internet connection maybe needs a
talent Booker and you know maybe an
assistant or something so he can make 90
98 99 percent net margins so that was
about six or seven months ago and in
that same article I basically said look
Joe Rogan is 10 times bigger than the
current audience of you know serious and
and Howard Stern it's insane that he's
probably a billionaire and he just
doesn't know it yet he's got billions of
dollars of oil under his farm and so
Rogan you know he could go subscription
just like Howard Stern and do his own
deal he could just say now you got to
pay to listen to me let's do that that
doesn't seem like his vibe so what I'm
basically estimating is if he simply
just said one Episode a week or the last
20 minutes of every episode is
subscriber only they're still gonna be
ads and if you subscribe you get an
ad-free stream so the ads that are
edited out and you get the extra 20
minutes at the end of every episode or
one extra episode a week or something
and maybe some kind of exclusive content
for true fans maybe streaming video or
something like that and if you just
assume a 5% conversion rate which is you
know maybe his most loyal fans the
numbers are staggering right so I asked
me he could do somewhere between 60 to a
hundred million dollars a year at a
minimum with that hybrid approach maybe
more than that if he was a little more
recive and so you know as a business
person I look at this and I go this is
very very easy to execute this does not
require advanced technology it doesn't
acquire crazy business management it
doesn't require a big team he could
easily do that tomorrow and yet he ended
up opting to go to Spotify and while I
don't know the exact terms of his deal
from what's been reported in the Wall
Street Journal and stuff it's somewhere
in the range of 50 to a hundred million
dollars that's unclear of exactly how
its structured whether that's an annual
thing or whatever now everybody's saying
well he just licensed it so he just gave
them three years exclusive to go to
Spotify what I the reason why I think
that's a bad deal even let's say
lifestyle wise he just hates selling ads
he doesn't want to deal with he doesn't
want to think about this stuff I think
it's a bad deal because at the end of
the day these guys want impact they want
to be heard by as many people as
possible and they have this loud speaker
and I think they like that what he's
doing is giving over his direct line of
communication to his listeners his
podcast feed and the direct relationship
where he can put anything he wants in
that feed and it goes directly to the
subscribers he's now given that to
Spotify and Spotify is in the middle of
that and what it means is that over the
next three years if his audience doubles
when he leaves Spotify he loses all
those new subscribers and yeah maybe
they'll go find him once he leaves but
he loses that direct relationship and so
to me you never want to lose your direct
relationship with your customer when
you're an influencer to me it's like
imagine if Kylie Jenner or someone
that's huge on Twitter went out and said
hey guys I've sold my Twitter rights to
I don't know if CNN and now CNN is gonna
tweet on my behalf so you're losing all
those subscribers and all those
followers so well objectively Joe Rogan
is killing it and Howard Stern is
killing it - he's guys made 500 million
dollars or whatever I'm not criticizing
that as a business strategist I think
it's insane I think it's totally the
wrong move and I think that Rogan
he was just sitting on oil and he didn't
know how to drill it and he wasn't even
aware of it and so my argument is that
just do it himself but too late for that
yeah and I think part of this like
Howard Stern I actually went deep after
I read your piece and went back and it's
hard to remember Howard Stern signed
that original you know hundred million
dollars a year for five years in 2004
and so I said you know what what's he
been getting paid since then and he
basically signed a 12-year deal and and
the other data point I found is they
estimate that he made about ninety
million dollars last year so there's a
good chance he's been getting paid you
know 80 to 100 million bucks a year for
over a decade now right and so Bobby
would say hey that's not that big of a
deal but to your point I think that the
numbers are like close to only a million
people or so are listening to the show
now versus you see a rogue in who maybe
it's not directly competitive in terms
of the content but it's very similar and
he's got you know five or ten or fifteen
times the size of the audience and so
what that then leads to is this idea of
like the creator used to be very similar
to an actor right hey you select me I
participate in your movie you pay me a
fee and I move on and that's basically
what they were doing with advertisers
but now we're seeing across platforms
whether it's tick tock stars YouTube
podcasters whatever they're building
real businesses right and they're
looking at this as I need diversified
revenue streams and and they understand
that the value is in that audience and
so Kylie's probably the best example
where she built a billion-dollar
business off the back of having that
audience but are you seeing other
creators maybe people who are using kind
of paid podcasts and they have other
tools or just people who haven't gotten
into paid podcast yet but they're
building these multiple revenue streams
and can you talk a little bit about how
you see that playing out over time yeah
I mean I think um you know if you look
at like 1998 the model used to be okay
I'm gonna start a dumb you know yo mama
joke website on Yahoo and I'm gonna put
a bunch of ugly banners on it right I
think that's the era of podcasting we're
in right now and I think that people
will realize that not only is it better
to have subscriber support because you
get more buy-in people are more loyal
and and you don't really owe anyone
anything you can talk about any brand
you can say anything you want
there's no advertisers to pull their
advertising
as long as your audience likes you Oh
keeping you but that it's recurring and
it's higher-margin because you're not
you're not going through ad sales or
anything like that and I think for a lot
of podcasters they're anxious because
they have all these ads on but they
don't know maybe the CPM rates drop like
crazy in six months maybe all the
startups go away and they're they're not
gonna fund podcast advertising maybe
Squarespace lowers the budget may be
audible lowers the budget right so I
think that it's just a better model and
we're seeing this across all media that
ultimately subscription for software
newsletters podcasting etc it's just
it's just better in so many ways so I
think that over time that realization is
gonna hit and if you think about it
there's already all these models already
exist in plain sight right you look at
Ben Thompson that strategy has been
writing a subscription newsletter that's
pay only with a few pieces of content
previewed for free publicly since 2014 I
think I don't know anything I think he's
making millions of dollars doing that
and now it wasn't until 2019 that sub
stack popped up and all these writers
started going hey I can go direct
consumer I don't need to go work for New
York Times they can write my own
newsletter and as long as I have a
thousand true fans I can make a living
and overtime I can compound those fans
and grow it significantly you know in
the podcasting world Sam Harris has been
doing this since 2013 right and he
doesn't have any advertising I have no
idea what he's doing revenue wise but I
would assume he's doing well if it's
still working and he just doubled down
on his subscription stuff now after 30
minutes it just cuts off and he says hey
if you want to keep listening on every
single episode you've got to pay so I I
think there's people that are doing it
very successfully and we've helped
people with super cast and with our art
podcast agency double-up
we've helped all sorts of people find
the oil underneath their plot of land
you know be we've I can name names but
there's multiple people who are like
influencers with huge audiences and they
were making so little money off it
because they're not business people
right and so we were able to help them
you know build a sustainable business
and that's such a cool thing for us
right to show people hey you know you
you're a farmer but now you're you know
we're with ten million dollars right